eu posso ver seu temos que tem esse tipo
de coisas aqui no estúdio é isso meu
raquete ping pong nunca deve olá pessoal
aqui quem fala é o dark sejam muito bem
vindos a mais um vídeo e hoje trago-vos
aqui se lembra dessa coisinha aqui no
canal já deixe aqui muito like neste
vídeo porque talvez a partir de hoje
vamos retomar que este sério ok é isso
que eu tenho aqui é um microscópio
microscópio o que é capaz de fazer mil
vezes um ok se aproximar mil vezes as
coisas eu já tenho uma série de vídeos
aqui no canal utilizar este microscópio
e portanto vocês não conhecem a série e
vou deixar aqui embaixo acompanha em que
o que é que nós vamos fazer aqui hoje
porque é que outros óculos estou de
barba por fazer e tal estou aqui
limpando eu andei à procura de umas
encomendas no isso que eu tenho recebido
aqui em casa e eu recebi esta encomenda
e eu recebi esta encomenda muito
suspeita uma encomenda que eu nem lembro
de ter feito e aqui dentro meus amigos
eu recebi esta embalagem
bom aparentemente são coisas que dá para
ver ao microscópio ok são tipo coisas
retiradas do lugares para se conseguir
ao microscópio está bem e é precisamente
isso que nós vamos ver aqui hoje pessoal
hoje aqui no vídeo nós vamos ver as
amostras que eu recebi da luiz eu
comprei essa toda a fazer este vídeo nem
tirei o uso a fazer empresa paga não fiz
nada estou aqui vendo outra mas vamos lá
então só ver o que é que chegou para
quem nunca viu um microscópio funcionar
ok eu vou aproximar aqui da minha pele e
vocês vão ver o poder de zoom que isto
tenha é vamos focar preciso ficar aqui
olha isso há muito tempo que não pegava
neste microscópio vejam como a minha
pele está oleosa e como os pelos são bem
grossos assim desperta não é pelo excel
estranho né acho que está sujo eu acho
que aquilo é distante da câmera mas não
vamos ligar estou vindo aqui ao
microscópio o que eu posso ter aqui na
minha mão ok eu estou a tentar encontrar
o lixo porque normalmente a mão é o
sítio onde mais concentra lixo eu vou
tentar aqui ó tem que um pelo olha aí
este pelo aqui eu não
e não dá para ver a minha mão está
completamente limpa eu aqui tipo não
consigo atingir a de nenhuma mas se eu
colocar o microscópio vocês vão você
sempre encontra a lista aqui bem que
dizem que uma mão é bem mais suja do que
uma sanita né porque até mais impurezas
e micróbios e tudo mais tem que pedaços
de pele olha aí braços de pele tempo
seca morta sei lá enfim pessoal vamos lá
então bora lá então ver aqui as amostras
que eu recebi ok primeira mostra é agar
agar eu acho que é uma planta o que isto
até buga aqui o microscópio
o whats parece tipo uma clara do ovo né
olha aí
e ai esta coisa aqui no meio estava
lugar muito microscópio a deve ter muita
luz aqui
o ok esta coisa aqui que eu quero vamos
tentar focar eu vou ficar ainda mais eu
vou dar 11 mil vezes porque eu não tava
mil vezes ok o tipo uma isso leia pense
umas gotas aqui ok nada demais não é
assim tão impressionante dá para ver
assim uma geleia mas como eu também não
sei ao certo que planta é este não é
assim tão interessante olha esse também
tem uma planta se sente favor podem é
pólen de girassol 1321 como é que será o
girassol olha isso o tempo pelo até não
chegasse ontem pelo ok vou dar aqui nos
uma alto só para ter uma noção do que é
que tá aqui ou o teste mentes não é o
bola né aliás é o pólen quero ver
aquelas bolinhas que isto é o que estou
falando girassol
e era um jeito mas ao mesmo tempo tem
uma coisa como é que tem uma raiz assim
a sair né do pólen então esse é o casa
velha chupão só estas gotas assim fm
pessoal isso é pólen de girassol
incrível tem um pobre com um pelo outro
falar não cumpriu tem tudo pelo aqui
mais uma planta block block surf blocos
o que é detox esta textura é boa pera aí
faz lembrar tipo sei lá um leopardo ou
umas fita aí ok tem aqui essa linha
vermelha é isso que eu preciso isto sim
é da planta do fox live que não sei não
faço ideia do que é flocos mas deve ser
assim uma erva como né eu vou de uma
ponta à outra para vocês conseguirem ver
bem olha aí
o meu que num microscópio isto é muito
comprido hocks casa da outra ponta bom
enfim não é assim tão impressionante bem
que esta textura aqui por acaso até é
bonita é bonita mas não é pelo pelo
encontramos aqui mais frio ok estamos
aqui outra planta lili pólen é isto ai a
certeza é a primeira okay expressam tipo
uns feijões tem uma coisa ali vermelha
que não sei o que é que não pode aqui
muito mais escuro também estranhas cola
na que eu não sei se é uma semente
o ok tem esta geleia aqui toda a volta
também é princípios das leis da
psicóloga para eles conseguirem colar o
escola anos no vidro é em princípio deve
ser isso acho que não tem nada a ver com
a planta porque como podem ver aqui ó a
cola bem diz lá de fora então deve ter
mesmo cola mas comentem pessoal
ajudem-me a decifrar o que é que isto é
ok mas aparentemente não aqui mais nada
isto é cola de cílios cada bambu bora lá
3 x 1 vamos lá ver a cana de bambu
também tem esta geleia ok clareamento
isto é a cola que é claramente e bora lá
que mais para o centro e essa parte do
primeiro eu não sei de onde é que isto
possa vir da cana mas se diz aqui que é
uma cara eu vou acreditar ok não tem
nada demais é só isso líquido aqui todo
por dentro mas agora não sei se isto é
cola não ficamos sempre aqui na dúvida
camélia póvoa de carioca está tudo
plantas ok camélia camélia camélia onde
está nossa camélia aqui no centro
é isso um tudo isso sozinhos que isso
é isso daqui são bem mais importantes
estão bem grande e tem-se uma coisa
volta estranha uma gelatina ok já fiquei
aqui mais nem uma bola aqui com uma
coisa preta que isto será lixo não é
muito louco ok ok ok eu postei aqui do
paulão da camélia próxima planta podem
de tulipa vamos lá ver o que é que tem
cola eu sabia oque é muito parecido
mesmo
eu acho que não há nada de novo aqui ok
a volta não tem nada é só aquele like de
estranho e aqui temos o power pronto
acho que é só isso ness teve um pessoal
que é que vocês acharam aqui deste vídeo
é escolher é só plantas deve ter outros
pectus também com animais ou com outro
tipo de coisas estranhas que eu vou
tentar investigar esse vou encomendar
aqui para vocês mas vocês tem que deixar
muito like nesse vídeo e tem que
comentar muito diferente da série de
volta a ser em um microscópio eu já
tentei também comentaram microscópio
mais potente mas não correu muito bem eu
vou tentar outra vez ok vamos ver se eu
consigo arranjar este facto porque vocês
sabem a microscópios conseguem atingir
tipos um de 10 mil vezes 20 mil vezes e
é isso que eu quero agora é só um
pouquinho mais caros mas eu vou tentar
arranjar da outra vez de um problema
então vou tentar arranjar outra vez com
outro fornecedor ou com outra pessoa e
vamos ver o que é que vai lá fazer só
para tenham gostado este vídeo e fiquem
bem e até a próxima tchau
e aí
[Música]